today's new member of the day is
Christopher earned this is viewer and
listener supported media be one of the
good guys and gals like Christopher
Hearn sign up at www.mathantics.com sign
up for our newsletter and January 1 you
will get an email with instructions
about how to take advantage if you want
of the biggest membership special of the
year okay we have a ton of syria-related
stories to discuss today and they're all
related to this just remarkably erratic
and confusing decision that Donald Trump
made to pull troops out of Syria General
Wesley Clark is now claiming that our
allies are wondering whether Donald
Trump may have been blackmailed into
pulling troops out of Syria because the
decision is so confusing so erratic and
run so counter to what we were told that
the Defense Department and Pentagon
planned to do now before I get into the
analysis I every time I talk about this
I need to say the following because
otherwise well I'm still going to get
emails about it but I'll get even more
emails if I don't do it let me be super
clear even if you were originally
against getting involved in Syria in the
first place you can still recognize that
once there there are good and bad
reasons to get out and if you do decide
to get out you want to be sure that
there is a strategic reason to do so
that's not going to make problems even
worse or give truly horrible people
license to be even more horrible and one
of the things that we learned over the
holiday long weekend is that Donald
Trump's bizarre decision which again
went directly against what we were told
weeks prior that the United States would
be doing which is staying in Syria for a
while Trump's
came after he spoke on the phone with
Turkish president air Dhawan who told
him don't worry about the Kurds it's all
going to be fine I give you my word so
on the heels of that in comes General
Wesley Clark and asks the sort of
increasingly important question why did
Trump do this and was there some kind of
blackmail let's take a look at the clip
well I'm very concerned because it
doesn't seem to be any strategic
rationale for the decision and if
there's no strategic rationale for the
decision then you have to ask why was
the decision made I can tell you that
people around the world are asking this
and some of our friends and allies in
the Middle East are asking well did did
hurt or one thing bail the president was
there a payoff or something what is it
why would a guy make a decision like
this because all the recommendations
were against it and it looked like that
all the facts are against it - we're not
quite finished with Isis we're not
taking a lot of casualties over there
the Kurds have been reliable allies so
why do this right now this is not about
imperialism versus anti-imperialism
although that's a perfectly good debate
to have this is not about whether or not
the United States should be the world's
policeman which I think it should not
that's a reasonable debate this is not
about pacifism versus war Hawkin we are
in Syria Bashar al-assad and Putin are
aligned air Dewan wants to destroy the
Kurds the Kurds are one of the few
groups that the US has recently
supported where we haven't had a total
backfire yet at least so the question is
why is Trump doing this and maybe more
importantly why is he doing it now after
showing his tough-guy cards previously
on Syria and blackmail and payoffs
involving Turkey are one possibility
there are all sorts of other
possibilities involving Russia there's
also a slightly more indirect connection
to Saudi Arabia related to Shamal
khashoggi and I want to explain that one
to you because it's number one not
totally obvious
and number two fortunately getting more
and more traction because you might hear
me say Jamal khashoggi Syria
what does pulling troops from Syria have
to do
with Turkey and Saudi Arabia and Shamal
Khashoggi and this is a very interesting
theory remember Donald Trump didn't
denounce Saudi Arabia over the khashoggi
killing which took place in Turkey
that's an important factor here
Turkey's investigation was one of the
early intelligence sources that pointed
to the Saudis which of course we know
now were responsible Turkey would
reasonably want Donald Trump to denounce
Saudi Arabia Trump says as we know not
going to do it
so Turkey says well then we need
something in this entire thing Trump
says what do you want and Turkey says
how about control of northern Syria
meaning you out of northern Syria Putin
likes it and consents or whatever
depending on what degree of involvement
you think Vladimir Putin has and then
that's how you get exactly these
circumstances so Pat blackmails a
possibility the Shamal Khashoggi
connection is a possibility Putin the
puppet master is a possibility but
what's clear is even if you were against
getting into Syria in the first place
which many of us were there is so much
going on here that should make us
question the underpinnings of this and
I'm hearing it more and more but there
are still people resistant to it saying
we should just be glad we're out period
well just the idea that our president is
being blackmailed
that's problematic but it's a perfectly
reasonable conversation to have knowing
that our president is compromised by
these foreign countries by turkey by
Saudi Arabia by Russia and you know
there were plenty of foreign policy
decisions made by former presidents like
Obama for example that I disagreed with
but I never once suspected that maybe
he's being blackmailed the fact that
we're in that situation right now that's
a problem people on the right are out of
bad faith saying I thought you liberals
wanted the United States out of Syria
and now you're complaining and there are
some people on the left being sort of
falsely tricked into commending Trump
for this because they don't want to
appear partisan when it comes to the
military once again just because you
thought going into Syria and the first
place was a bad idea doesn't mean that
you have to ignore the obvious red flags
about why Trump made this decision right
now and fascinatingly
some liberals are tied up in a knot
because even Noam Chomsky says that this
stinks to high heaven and that the US
should have stayed in to protect the
Kurds and that's what I want to talk
about next